Mona Vetsch - drei Tage bei DJ BoBo.
Auf nichts vorbereitet,
aber auf alles gefasst.
Das ist "Mona mittendrin".
Lieber Mani,
das hier ist dein neuer Lehrling.
Das ist Mona.
- Hallo, Mona. Ich bin Mani.
Sehr erfreut.
- Heute schaut sie noch zu.
Heute kannst du noch zuschauen.
Da hast du Glück.
Du lernst zwei Tage lang. Und
an der Weltpremiere bist du dran.
Ja.
Dann lasse ich euch jetzt.
- Gut, super.
Und ich zeige dir, was wir machen.
Wir gehen jetzt mal backstage.
- Ja.
* "Pray" von DJ BoBo läuft ab Band. *
(Während auf der Bühne schon jeder
plus/minus weiss, was er zu tun hat,
habe ich von meinem neuen Metier
noch keine Ahnung.)
Wie um Gottes Willen
wird man Pyrotechniker?
Was ist in deiner Jugend
schiefgelaufen?
Ich hab noch beide Hände.
- Ah, ja.
Das ist aber
nicht selbstverständlich.
Ich komme aus dem Lichtbereich
beim Theater, Requisiten.
So hat sich das ergeben.
Es musste immer mal blitzen
und kleine Explosionen geben.
Weil es immer mehr wurde,
habe ich mich spezialisiert.
(Er ist bekannt als Pyro-Mani.)
(Und er arbeitet
schon seit 20 Jahren
mit Rene Baumann alias DJ BoBo.)
(Jetzt zeigt er mir sein Arsenal.
Alles hoch explosive Ware.)
(Jeden Effekt probiere er bei sich
zu Hause im Thüringer Wald aus,
bevor er ihn auf die Bühne bringt.)
Dazu braucht es flüssiges Gas.
Das geht nach oben.
Okay. Welches Gas ist das?
- CO2.
Wir fangen gleich an.
Das kannst du hier hinkleben.
- Und da beim Bühnenaufgang?
Drüben und hinten,
damit da auch keiner raucht.
Okay, ist gut.
(Als Pyro-Lehrling
beginne ich ganz unten.)
(Andere haben mit komplexeren
Aufgaben zu kämpfen.)
(Z.B. mit dieser Hebebühne.)
(Die wird so steil,
dass alle angegurtet werden müssen.)
(Dumm ist nur: Sie können sich
danach nicht mehr vom Gurt lösen.)
(Auch BoBos Frau Nancy
bleibt hängen.)
Wie funktioniert's denn?
- Man muss rausdrücken.
Man denkt immer, man müsse
runterdrücken. Aber hier nicht.
Ah, du bräuchtest
eine zweite Hand fürs Aufdrücken.
Kannst du das bei Nancy machen?
- (Mann) Ja.
Es ist nicht einfach, nicht wahr?
Es geht nicht nur mir so.
- Ah, reindrücken.
Wow!
Ich bin froh, dass nicht nur ich
so bescheuert bin.
Hast du an dir gezweifelt?
Ich dachte:
"Scheisse, blond - blöd!"
(Sie wirken alle
noch erstaunlich locker auf mich.)
(Aber das täusche.
Der Druck sei immens.)
Ich schlafe schon seit Tagen nicht.
Ich träume immer davon,
dass nichts fertig ist.
Wir gehen auf die Bühne
und haben nichts anzuziehen.
Die Kostüme sind nicht fertig.
So ist es.
Wirklich? Noch nicht fertig?
- Noch nicht ganz.
Aber ihr braucht sie doch
heute Abend.
Die Hälfte ist halt nicht da.
Da müssen wir durch. Also ihr.
Es gibt immer
Plan F, Plan X, Plan Z.
Wie viele Programme
habt ihr schon zusammen gemacht?
Das ist wohl das 13. oder 14.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Wird das einfacher mit
der Erfahrung? Diese Ängste und ...
Nein.
Doch, man hat die Gewissheit,
dass am Schluss alles gut wird.
Stimmt. Heute vielleicht nicht.
Aber das ist nicht so wichtig.
Du bist ein totaler Perfektionist.
Ich glaube dir nicht, wenn du
sagst, es sei nicht wichtig.
Es ... hm.
- Das ist unsere Generalprobe.
Ja, so ist es auch angekündigt.
Obwohl heute Publikum da ist.
Die wissen das.
Ich sage es auch
gleich bei der Begrüssung:
"Wir sind dabei zu proben. Vieles
wird noch nicht funktionieren."
Wir müssen heute wohl
auch die Videoleinwände ausmachen,
weil sie zeitversetzt sind.
Warum ist das so?
- Ich will gar nicht alles wissen.
Ich schon.
- Das ist dein Job.
Wenn ich auch noch wüsste, warum ...
Eine Besprechung.
- Jetzt gilt's ernst.
Jungs, Kameras aus! Tschüss, weg!
Danke.
(Wenn's ans Eingemachte geht,
lässt sich Rene Baumann
nicht gerne in die Karten schauen.)
(Ich gehe in die Schneiderei, um zu
schauen, wie weit die Kostüme sind.)
Hi there. Sprecht ihr Deutsch?
- Ja, ja, wir sind aus der Schweiz.
Ah, gut. Super.
Man sagte uns, gerade
arbeite niemand so hart wie ihr.
Ja, wir sind wirklich
fast Tag und Nacht dabei.
Um 23.30 Uhr ins Bett,
um 6 Uhr wieder aufgestanden,
um 7 Uhr losgelegt. Ja.
Machst du so etwas öfter?
Ich bin fast seit Beginn
bei Rene dabei.
Und wie kamst du dazu?
Rene hat mal bei mir gewohnt,
als er noch ledig war.
Ich war auch Haushälterin
und Nanny seiner Kinder.
Ich bin immer noch Haushälterin.
- Wirklich?
Was für ein Typ ist Rene?
Wie würdest du ihn beschreiben?
Er ist bodenständig.
Er ist am Boden geblieben.
Er ist sehr nett. Er ist
wie ein grosser Sohn für mich.
(Chefdesignerin ist aber nicht
Therese, sondern Nancy, BoBos Frau.)
(Als Sängerin
hat sie in den 90er-Jahren
mit verschiedenen Hitparadestürmern
auf der Bühne gestanden.)
Habt ihr erst zusammen gearbeitet
und wurdet dann erst ein Paar?
Nein, andersrum.
Und ich hatte grossen Respekt davor.
Er meinte: "Wir sehen uns nie,
das geht so nicht."
Dann meinte ich:
"Gut, wir probieren es aus."
"Ich mache eine Tour. Aber
wenn es nicht geht, bin ich weg."
Und es ging super.
Ich sagte: "Du musst mir Platz
lassen, und ich lasse dir deinen."
Es ist alles
nur eine Frage des Respekts.
Was ist dein Platz?
Ich will arbeiten,
ohne dass er mir reinredet.
Also du sagst ihm auch,
was er anzuziehen hat. - Ja.
Da hat er nichts zu sagen?
- Nein.
Oh.
Ich sage ihm auch nicht,
was er komponieren soll. Oder?
Ja, stimmt.
- Ist doch fair.
Wir sprachen gerade darüber, dass du
nichts zur Garderobe zu sagen hast,
das sei ihr Bereich.
- Ja.
Ausser es funktioniert etwas nicht.
War das Lied, das ich
geschrieben habe, recht, Schatz?
(Mann) Nancy!
- Ja?
Komm kurz runter!
- Komme!
Maurizia!
- Ah, Maurizia.
Da muss ich kurz gehen.
(Nancy und BoBo sind 18 Jahren
verheiratet und haben zwei Kinder.)
(Und überhaupt:
Ich kann hier fragen, wen ich will,
praktisch jeden verbindet
eine lange Geschichte mit BoBo.)
(Auch viele Tänzer.)
War er ein Held für dich?
Ja. Ich war auch an seinem Konzert.
Als Junge?
- Ja, ja. Ich hörte seine Musik.
Ich fand es cool
und wollte auch mal mitmachen.
Bei dir war es dasselbe.
Wir machten zusammen die Audition
und vor zehn Jahren die erste Tour.
Das Geile ist, auf der Bühne
zu stehen und "Freedom" zu tanzen.
Nur schon das.
- Warum?
Weil man das
schon früher immer gesehen hat.
Und dann steht man selber da.
Wie im Film.
Also der kleine Junge,
der mit der Haarbürste singt.
Genau. Bei mir war es
nicht das Singen, sondern Tanzen.
Ich habe es
einfach immer nachgetanzt.
(Zum Glück kann ich
das Tanzen anderen überlassen.)
(Meine Aufgabe ist der Knalleffekt.)
(An der Weltpremiere muss ich
mit dieser Kanone hantieren.)
Also, jetzt. Das ist das Teil.
Das ist das Teil.
- Oder?
Halt mal, bitte!
- Ja.
Es wird mein Job sein: Zum Höhepunkt
der DJ-BoBo-Premiere werde ich ...
... im Publikum
das Konfetti verteilen.
Wir freuen uns drauf.
- Ja, ich freue mich wirklich.
(Es sind nur noch einige Minuten bis
zum Startschuss der Generalprobe.)
(Ein BoBo-Tänzer der ersten Stunde
steht dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal
nicht mehr auf der Bühne.)
(Curtis, der Erfinder
aller BoBo-Choreografien.)
Ah, hier ist Curtis. Wie geht's?
Seltsam.
Seit wann arbeitest du mit Rene?
- Seit ich 14 war.
Er war 17, ich 14.
- Ja.
Also 30 Jahre.
- Ihr seid so.
Es ist seltsam,
nicht auf der Bühne zu stehen,
nicht noch etwas üben zu müssen.
Aber ich bin mega happy und gehe
in meiner neuen Rolle voll auf.
(Dieses Jahr
führt Curtis erstmals Regie.)
(Er hält
das ganze Programm zusammen.)
(Mein Job heute:
Pyro-Mani auf die Finger schauen.)
(An die grossen Flammenwerfer
lässt er mich aber
auch bei der Weltpremiere nicht.)
(Dafür braucht man eine Lizenz.)
Wie heiss ist denn das Zeug,
das du da ...?
Die Flammen
sind schon richtig heiss.
Wie bei einem Lagerfeuer.
Richtig heisse Temperaturen.
Ich darf ja keine Flammen auslösen.
Nein, du machst die ungefährlichen
Sachen. Konfetti und so was.
Da bin ich ... Diese Verantwortung
würde ich nicht tragen wollen.
Aber du musst darauf achten,
dass vor der Kanone
nicht gerade ein Kind steht.
Wenn du dann drückst, das wär blöd.
So, ladies and gentlemen.
Enjoy the show tonight.
It's gonna be the first night.
Safety first, that's important.
Have fun on that stage and give
the best you can. Here we go.
(Alle) Oh!
* Sphärische Klänge *
(DJ BoBo) Somebody dance with me!
Hoho!
* Das Publikum singt nach. *
(BoBo kennt sein Metier. Er hat das
Publikum von Anfang an im Griff.)
# Somebody dance with me!
Somebody dance with me!
(Aber technisch
läuft es noch nicht, wie es sollte.)
(Die Hebebühne bleibt ein Problem.)
(Das Abgurten bei Nancy hinten
rechts klappt immer noch nicht.)
# ... I get this feeling,
you're the only one.
# Feel so proud, sweet, sweet girl,
your love is all around.
# Love is all around, love
is all around, love is all around.
(Auch bei den Kostümen
passt noch lange nicht alles.)
(Therese schreibt minutiös mit.)
(Bei diesem Song müssten eigentlich
vier flying robots
um DJ BoBo herumfliegen,
aber nur einer hebt wirklich ab.)
# A million dreams
are keeping me alive.
(Nur Mani hat alles im Griff.)
# ... and you pray.
(Chor) # Pray!
Das ist ja richtig ...
Da wird einem richtig heiss.
* Das Publikum jubelt. *
Ich bin fertig mit der Welt.
Danke.
Wo soll das hin? Nach oben?
- Ja, bitte.
Die Stimmung war toll. Aber
wir haben noch viel zu arbeiten.
Okay.
War einiges schon gut?
The holy glitter war gut.
(Nach der Show gehen alle
direkt zur Lagebesprechung.)
(Also -
alle, ausser ich und die Kamera.)
Ab hier ist jetzt Feierabend.
- Wir verstecken uns.
Nein, nein.
- Doch, doch.
(Wenn kritisiert wird, ist man
beim BoBo-Team lieber unter sich.)
(Besprochen
wird bis tief in die Nacht.)
(Der ganze Ablauf
sei umgestellt worden,
erfahre ich am nächsten Morgen.)
(Das hat grosse Auswirkungen
auf jeden Einzelnen.)
(Besonders unter Druck: die Jungs
mit den fliegenden Robotern.)
(Die Hauptprobe lief für sie
alles andere als optimal.)
Seid ihr nervös?
Schon etwas. Es sind
die kleinen technischen Probleme.
Man stellt die Teile
für die Show her.
Es ist kein Produkt ab Regal,
das einfach funktioniert.
Es hat Kinderkrankheiten.
Mal geht dies nicht, mal das.
Und hier
haben wir extreme Magnetfelder.
Wegen der Stahlkonstruktionen?
- Wir wissen es nicht.
Es scheint, als wechsle es z.T.
sogar. Dann drehen die Dinger durch.
Und ihr auch.
- Natürlich.
Wenn sie Pirouetten drehen,
die sie nicht sollten.
Darum kämpfen wir ein bisschen.
(Wo ich auch hinsehe -
alle arbeiten fiebrig.)
Dann muss ich es so machen. Die
beiden gehen raus, die beiden hoch.
Aber die Plattform bleibt?
Ja, wenn man die Krone machen will.
(Ich bin zwar mittendrin,
aber doch irgendwie aussen vor.)
(In Plauderlaune
ist hier definitiv niemand.)
* Abwartende, rhythmische Musik *
(Leise) Sie machen
wohl gerade BoBos Kostüm fertig.
Irgendetwas ist noch nicht
ganz so, wie es sollte.
* Unverständliche Gespräche *
Was habt ihr gemacht?
- Vieles.
Vieles?
- Alles neu.
Dieser Tage sieht man BoBo immer
nur durch Türen ein- und austreten.
Ähm, willst du noch mal kurz kommen?
Wir haben hier das Neopren...
Was die Materialien angeht.
Schauen wir mal,
ob das funktionieren kann,
mit dem, was sie zuschneidet.
Und wenn nicht,
dann machen wir einen grossen Stich.
Ja, auf alle Fälle.
- Okay.
Woran arbeitet ihr im Moment?
- Ach, an Details an Kostümen.
Aber da müssen wir
erst mal eine Lösung finden.
Ja, ja. Tontechnische, chemische ...
Eine neue Welt.
Was auch immer das heisst.
Aber im Moment sind alle
ziemlich in ihrer eigenen Welt.
Man muss nicht viel reden wollen.
(Alle rennen. Nur Mani nicht.)
(In der BoBo-Entourage
ist er der ruhende Pol.)
In diesem Graben steht alles drin.
Das ist versenkt,
damit man es vorne nicht sieht.
Die Leute stehen ja davor.
Da stehen Nummern drauf.
Das ist wichtig.
Nummer 1, 2, 3 bis 10.
- Aha, okay.
Gut. Nimmst du den schon?
- Ich nehme den schon mit.
(In diesem Graben
sind Feuerwerkskasten drin.)
(Diese müssen wir nachladen.)
Oh. Jetzt willst du es aber wissen.
* Mani lacht. *
Ich dachte ...
- Stell sie hier ab.
Ich wollte nicht noch einmal laufen.
- Ich hab's dir angeboten.
Zeigt Rene dir zuerst alles,
was er vorhat,
und dann sagst du,
was du dir vorstellen kannst?
Wir machen das meistens zusammen.
Die Bühne wird geplant und dann
gibt es den entsprechenden Platz.
Dann überlegen wir uns,
was passen könnte.
Welcher Effekt passt zur Musik?
Und dann zeige ich ihm
die Effekte, die es so gibt.
Aber du bist in diesem ganzen Or-
chester von BoBo eigentlich der ...
Wie heissen die? Die Paukenspieler.
Die braucht es fast nie, aber ...
- ... im richtigen Moment ...
... Bam!
- Genau, im richtigen Moment.
Paukenspieler. Das ist gut.
(Curtis hat seine Tänzer
zusammengetrommelt.)
Okay, first of all:
Thank you, everybody.
Danke für eure Power.
Ich möchte, dass ihr euch
auf der Bühne alle wohlfühlt.
Mike soll Mike sein
und Massimo Massimo.
Ich will keine perfekte Roboter
sehen, sondern Persönlichkeiten.
Ich wäre heute so gerne mit euch
auf der Bühne. Lasst es krachen!
Okay. He's gonna take you ... Ach!
* Die Tänzer
machen aufmunternde Laute. *
(Der Abschied von der Bühne
nach über 20 Jahren -
für einen Vollbluttänzer wie Curtis
nicht leicht.)
(BoBo habe ich heute
erst im Vorbeirennen gesehen.)
(Ich pirsche mich noch einmal an. Er
ist immer noch in der Schneiderei.)
Genau, wir wollten noch festlegen,
was ich da mache.
Was ich probiert hatte,
funktioniert nicht.
* Unverständliche Gespräche *
Ich sehe nichts.
- Bitte?
Das muss man noch kaufen.
Ich sehe nichts.
Siehst du's nicht?
- Nein.
Besprühen
kann man das nicht, weil ...
Aber kannst du es nicht drauf nähen?
- Das hab ich schon.
Du warst nicht zufrieden?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Aber das war klar.
Wenn man erstmals
etwas vor Publikum ausprobiert,
bekommt man Feedback
und spürt sofort, wo man
im emotionalen Bogen unterwegs ist.
Das muss stimmen.
Das ist für mich das Wichtigste.
Warst du nach der Show sauer
oder enttäuscht?
Nein, fokussiert. Schon während der
Show weiss ich, was ich ändern will.
Dann denke ich schon ans Umsetzen.
Das hat halt viele Auswirkungen.
Du bist eigentlich das Zentrum.
Kann man das so sagen?
Ja. Ich bin auch der Motor. Wenn du
mich rausnimmst, geht's nicht mehr.
Die anderen müssen Benzin geben und
ich bin der Motor, der dann läuft.
So. Jetzt wieder zurück.
Ich bekomme ein Kleidchen.
(Der Motor läuft turbo. Geschlafen
wird auch in dieser Nacht wenig.)
(So eine Produktion zu stemmen,
ist eine Grenzerfahrung für alle.)
Ich habe auch schon gedacht,
es sei mal die letzte Tournee.
Aber mal sehen.
- Was gefällt dir denn daran?
Die Menschen.
Es ist einfach wie eine Familie.
Es ist so eine tolle Crew.
Und mein Mann ist pensioniert. Man
kann nicht immer aufeinander hocken.
Da ist das doch
ein schöner Ausgleich.
Was steht denn heute an?
- Jetzt müssen wir flicken.
Flicken?
- Ja.
(Auch die Robotercrew
brütet schon wieder.)
Wie ist der Stand der Dinge?
Ähm, heute Morgen um 5 Uhr
haben wir etwas gefunden.
Und jetzt sieht es aus,
als könnten wir fliegen.
Heute um 5 Uhr? Wart ihr
immer noch wach oder schon wieder?
Wir haben 4 Std. geschlafen.
Etwas Schlaf ist nötig.
Was für ein Chef ist BoBo?
Schimpft er manchmal?
Nein,
er ist eigentlich sehr angenehm.
Als wir schon aufgeben wollten,
meinte er: "Probiert's einfach."
(Dass heute alle vier
in die Luft schwirren -
Regisseur Curtis
gibt sich überzeugt.)
Da freue ich mich.
- Ich mich auch.
Es wird genial heute.
- Wenn du's sagst.
Nur etwas mehr Selbstvertrauen.
- Du weisst mehr als ich.
Dafür sind Proben ja da.
- Die Hauptprobe geht immer schief.
Wie geht's deinem Kopf?
Ich fänd's genial,
wenn sie es schaffen,
eine beständig fliegen zu lassen.
So habe ich das
schon gestern mit ihnen besprochen.
Und wir haben jetzt alles gemacht:
Die Startplätze sind vorne.
Ich bewege mich nur vorne.
Alles gut.
(DJ BoBo redet überall mit:
Von den fliegenden Robotern
bis zum Ticketverkauf - er weiss
genau, wie er es haben will.)
Also, Stefan, das müssen wir
schaffen. Frankfurt oben auf.
Oben, oben, oben, unterm Dach.
- Ja.
Es ist nicht die Frage,
ob wir es schaffen, das aufzumachen.
Nein, ich will, dass es voll ist.
- Aha.
Das ist der Punkt.
Wir wollen ihn verkaufen.
In welchem Moment wird DJ BoBo
vom Manager, Geschäftsmann
nur noch zum Künstler?
Weiss ich nicht.
Wann bin ich nur noch Künstler?
Und wann bin ich
auch an anderem interessiert?
Nö, du bist immer alles.
- Alles, ja.
Mich interessiert auch alles.
- Das war schon immer so.
Mich interessiert es auch:
Warum ist die Kamera nicht gut,
warum ist das Bild nicht,
wie ich denke usw.?
Bist du je zufrieden?
- So lange ich Neues machen darf.
Du wirst mich nie
an der Fastnacht im Festzelt sehen,
wie ich meine alten Hits spiele.
Schwörst du das?
- Ja, das ist einfach.
Denn Geld ist für mich kein Antrieb.
Ich will etwas bewegen.
Würdest du dich schämen,
im Festzelt zu spielen?
Ich muss nicht.
Dafür habe ich gesorgt.
Rein finanziell müsstest du
den Job also nicht mehr machen.
Ich hatte die 90er-Jahre.
Damals verkaufte man CDs.
Das war der CD-Boom.
Da habt ihr mit dem Verkauf
von Musik richtig Kohle gemacht.
Genau. Das war früher noch so.
Und wenn man nicht ganz dumm war
und alles ausgegeben hat,
waren 15 Mio. Alben
nicht so schlecht.
Okay.
- Ja. Gut.
(Murmelnd)
"Wirst du nie zufrieden sein?"
Also, danke, Jungs!
(So eine Produktion
kostet rund 1 Mio. Fr.)
(DJ BoBo ist der einzige
Eurodance-Künstler aus den 90ern,
der noch Shows in
dieser Grössenordnung machen kann.)
(Dass er überlebt hat,
ist kein Zufall.)
(Mehr und mehr merke ich: Rene
Baumann ist nicht nur ein Künstler,
er ist v.a.
auch ein gewiefter Geschäftsmann.)
(Er hat eine Firma aufgebaut,
die sich um alles kümmert -
vom Verlagsrecht
bis zu den Fanartikeln.)
(Jeder Entscheid läuft über ihn.
Jeder.)
(Das zeigt sich auch
wenige Stunden vor der Premiere.)
Schweizer Franken. Achtung!
Es kommen bestimmt 20 % Schweizer.
Wie haben wir das gemacht?
Aber Bargeld haben sie alle in Euro.
- Und wenn einer keine hatte?
Dann haben wir
eins zu eins umgerechnet.
Eins zu eins?
- Natürlich.
Das ist aber nett für den Schweizer.
Okay, dann seid kulant
und macht 30 Fr. oder 30 Euro.
Es ist ja nicht mehr so weit
auseinander. Vielleicht 1.12.
Also, super. Bis gleich.
Ich mache mal Soundcheck.
Okay. Viel Spass. Bis gleich.
* Einzelne hallende Trommelschläge *
(Die ganz grossen Fans sind
schon beim Soundcheck mit dabei.)
(Sie kauften extra teurere Tickets,
um noch mehr BoBo
erleben zu können.)
* Aufgekratzte Gitarrenmelodie *
(Fan) Ich freue mich so,
ich kann es gar nicht erwarten.
Ich bin so aufgeregt.
Oh mein Gott, ich freue mich so!
Warum kommen dir gerade die Tränen?
Wir dürfen die Weltpremiere
in Reihe 5 erleben. Wahnsinn!
Geil!
Was gefällt euch an BoBo?
Die Show,
die Art, wie er dich mitnimmt.
Der steht nicht auf der Bühne
und macht sein Ding, sondern sagt:
"Stand up, mach Power, gib Gas, tanz
mit uns, feier mit, geniess das!"
Geil!
* Schlagzeug, laute Musik *
(Vom Band) # Respect yourself,
change your mind.
# Respect yourself, don't be blind.
Respect yourself.
(Während die Fans
schon jetzt im siebten Himmel sind,
geht Therese zwei Etagen weiter oben
durch die Hölle.)
Was für ein Stress.
(Drei Kostüme
sind noch nicht bereit.)
Wie ist dir zumute, Therese?
Jetzt darf ich gerade nichts sagen.
It's hard.
Jetzt brauchen wir
ein paar Minuten Ruhe.
(Ich muss eh zu Mani.
Gleich geht's los.)
Ich schalte das scharf,
das ist für das Konfetti.
Ich drehe den Schlüssel,
dann wird das rot.
Und dann drückst du drauf,
aber im richtigen Moment.
Schaffst du das?
- Ich hoff's.
Blamier mich nicht,
ich habe alles auf dich gesetzt.
Ja, ist gut.
* Unverständliches Gespräch *
(Versagen wäre ganz schlecht.)
(Schliesslich
haben DJ BoBo und sein Team
zwei Jahre
auf diesen Moment hingearbeitet.)
* Pulsierende Musik von der Bühne *
(Und jetzt ist es so weit:
die Weltpremiere.)
(Chor) # Respect yourself.
Change your mind.
(Therese hat es geschafft.
Alle haben etwas anzuziehen.)
# ... and you will see the light.
# Respect yourself.
And you will find a way.
# So practice what you pray.
Don't run away.
# Respect yourself.
(Sogar BoBos Lendenschurz
wurde rechtzeitig fertig.)
* Rhythmische Orgelmelodie *
(Jetzt kommt mein Einsatz
langsam näher.)
(Ich muss einfach
auf den roten Knopf drücken.)
(Aber genau im richtigen Moment.)
# I need you, whatever I do.
Tell me where, where is your love.
(Mein Plan,
damit ich es nicht verbocke:
Ich drücke einfach, wenn Pyro-Mani
neben mir auch drückt.)
(Achtung!)
* Knallen *
(Praktisch zeitgleich.)
(Oder wenigstens noch
im Toleranzbereich, hoffe ich.)
(Und dann der grösste Zittermoment:
Wie viele der vier Roboter
kommen zu fliegen?)
(Alle.)
(Das unermüdliche Tüfteln
hat sich gelohnt.)
(Im Chor) # Rising up
and we are standing tall.
# A million dreams
and we've got them all.
# Rising up and standing tall.
* Jubel, Applaus *
(DJ BoBo) Herzlichen Dank.
(Jetzt nur noch die Konfettikanone
zum Finale im Griff haben,
und alles ist gut.)
# There's a party.
- Everybody stand!
# Don't you know
today there is a party.
# I wanna see you now.
# Open up your heart,
we gonna start it.
Come on!
# Welcome at the beach,
this is for you, just for you.
Und das letzte Mal!
# Who-oh oh oh.
# There's a party.
Ha, das war's.
- Hast du super gemacht.
Hat alles geklappt.
Danke schön. Es war ein Riesenspass.
Es hat viel Spass gemacht.
Wohoo!
Dir geht's jetzt gut.
Jetzt bin ich erlöst.
- Wunderbar.
Ich habe zwar ein paar Teile auf
der Bühne liegenlassen, aber egal.
(Und was meint wohl der Chef?)
Vielen Dank.
- Ich danke dir.
Bist du zufrieden?
Du warst eine halbe Sekunde zu spät.
Nicht mit mir, sondern mit dem,
was du geliefert hast.
Ach so! War cool. Danke schön.
- Alles Gute für eure Tour.
Danke, dass wir dabei sein durften.
(Dem Perfektionisten DJ BoBo
entgeht nichts. Gar nichts.)
(Das habe ich
in diesen drei Tagen gelernt.)
(Für mich
endet die Reise mit BoBo hier.)
(Für alle anderen
geht sie erst richtig los.)
(Jetzt geht die ganze Truppe
gemeinsam auf Tournee.)
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Regina Kolb - 2019